back much which has been fought over for
the last six months looks now as if it
may fall to the Russians the Wagner
group who've been assaulting it pagosian
has said today that uh they've almost
got it and that's probably true I think
ukrainians will probably have to
withdraw from that much it won't matter
strategically it's this is a symbolic
victory in a symbolic defeat for the
ukrainians but there's not a lot of
strategic uh importance in that but
there is involada further south because
that's The High Ground dominates the
area around it and dominates the route
North and the Russians have been
attacking volada we've been watching
this for a couple of weeks now but it's
in the public domain so we can talk
about it which is the case that the uh
the ukrainians have been leaving the
roads not many roads intervalid they've
been leaving the roads open and clear
and putting mines in all the fields
between them very muddy uh wet fields at
the moment Russian tanks have been
coming up the roads have been being hit
and all the tanks behind them have been
transferring into the fields and hitting
the mines it's been a tremendous battle
between tanks and armored vehicles and
landmines and ukrainians are able keep
keep putting more Minds in both secretly
at night and also through artillery you
can actually use artillery to drop mines
into an area these days so the Russians
are doing quite poorly there meanwhile
in brienne's goblast get a little
village at lubushen which is quite near
to the uh to the Border uh with between
Ukraine and Russia there was an attack
uh the Russians called it a terrorist
attack it's very small attack by a group
who have claimed responsibility who are
calling themselves the uh the Russian
volunteer Corps within the international
unit that fights for the ukrainians and
almost certainly this is a bit of free
enterprise if it was a false flag attack
that the Kremlin has set up then it
would have been a lot more serious and
equally if it really was some sort of
sabotage attempt by the Ukrainian
government they'd have done it on a much
bigger scale this is a small scale thing
it's uh it's resulted in a certain
amount of death not very much but there
you are I think it's just a a bit of
free enterprise and it's not very
helpful to give meanwhile what is
helpful to give is the fact that there
is another Aid package on the way from
the United States uh 400 million dollars
which is getting on for half a billion
dollars which brings the US total up to
about 32 billion dollars a lot of it is
ammunition but some of it is this
snappily uh entitled that armored
vehicle launch Bridge that's an armored
vehicle launch bridge and what it is
it's a tank tank basis and it's Bridge
which is able to just throw out it
launches it the bridge is about 60 feet
long about 20 meters and it can go over
uh whatever it is and small rivers or
Ravines or any sort of obstacle on the
ground that troops need to get over it's
quick it's very efficient you know we
often talk about weapons whether there
are offensive and defensive weapons
there is no such thing as an offensive
or a defensive weapon depends what you
use it for but looking at weapons and
this is a non-lethal system altogether
this is probably 90 offensive because if
you're on the defense if you're falling
back you blow up the bridges and get the
other side of them if you're moving
forward you need something to get over a
small obstacles pretty quickly so this
is what troops use when they're moving
forward if they're going to get get
forward quickly and so there are eight
of them on their way according to the
United States the ukrainians will need
them because they need them for the
offensive which they're planning hasn't
started yet but when it does start it
will be conducted with some of the best
equipment in the world including the the
launch Bridge